berlin kreuzberg in die jahre gekommenes
alternativ viertel und kultureller
schmelztiegel vor allem kulinarisch hat
der berliner süden viel zu bieten und
damit sind nicht nur die döner läden an
jeder ecke gemeint dass goldies hat sich
innerhalb von neun monaten zu einem der
beliebtesten leben gemausert
dabei ist das goldies eigentlich eine
pommesbude aber eine mit anspruch
so kann der gast
entscheiden oder wir lernen die
getauscht gericht hat kriegt
mein gewicht hat natürlich der gewinner
wird
stammkunden die fleisch essen kriegen
sie ohne zu sparen
auf die idee mit den pommes deluxe
carmen flach dahin und kiesel während
ihrer ausbildung dass die beiden in
sternerestaurants gearbeitet haben merkt
man nicht nur an ihren 14 verschiedenen
soßen salz und zucker
das fleisch saftiger ist und dann machen
wir aus der haut und das gleich das wird
so anklage knochen oder fett dabei ist
dann kommt nur heute in florida zu
leicht süßlich ist
und dann halt die knusprige haut die
bürger ist sozusagen dann noch mal extra
aus dem all
und den gästen schmeckt es eine tonne
kartoffeln verbrauchers goalies in der
woche
neben der peking ente sind die pommes
mit schwarzen trüffeln besonders beliebt
[Musik]
einen knacks
eine portion kostet zwischen fünf und
zehn euro
alles natürlich auch zum mitnehmen ist
jetzt nicht investieren
es ist so ausgedrückt was es nicht gibt
ja genau das war die sache weil das ist
doch mal pommes irgendwie beides ist an
dem es beilage sondern beim bürger
wir haben überlegen was gibt es wirklich
nicht in berlin und da auch komplett auf
die idee wem das immer noch nicht genug
kolk elvis vergnügen ist für den gibt es
sogar pommes kunst im keller wartet eine
videoinstallation mit pommes gabeln
selbstverständlich frittiert
[Musik]